during his life ken kesey was at once a
counterculture and literary hero best
known for his book One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest before he died in 2001
kizi spoke to National Geographic about
his inspiring love of the Oregon coast
everybody who has come and seen the
ocean for the first time they get over
there and they look and they begin to
reflect you know whether it's a four
year old killer or 80 year old man
they're all of them go through something
in their minds and I think the human has
been gone through for a long long time
it's still treacherous out there when
I'm over there working alone at night
man you begin to think of stuff that you
think why am I thinking of this I'm i'm
thinking of ghosts and spirits and
things that move in the night
it makes you think of strange and
ancient magic the coast does
because you just hear that continual arm
and it moves you into another wavelength
when you see something over there it's
you see it in a different light than you
do anywhere else it's a wonderful place
to watch sunsets each one is different
and you will get the real theatrical
play on those clouds all the birds will
turn and watch the Sun go down
and you can sit out there and watch the
sky you're completely dark and every
moment is there's stuff going on it's a
humbling thing to go over there and move
along that coast but just something
about that edge between the land and the
water